in this video we're going to go into
some forms that are very useful when you
are filling out your income taxes if you
work for someone as an employee first
and foremost you're going to get a W-2
form and I always find the W-2 form
interesting you typically get it at the
beginning of a calendar year so that you
have it in time to file for your taxes
but it's a nice summary of what you are
paid and what was withheld either at a
federal level for federal income tax for
Social Security but you also see things
like state taxes withheld on top of that
and so this is just a nice summary and
for a lot of folks this is all the
information that you're going to need if
you don't have really complicated things
in your life if you don't have a
mortgage if you're not a landlord if
you're not an independent contractor
you're going to be able to fill out most
of your taxes usually using just this
form right over here now a lot of folks
have income above and beyond the wages
tips and other compensation that you get
from your W-2 or that you get from your
employer and that will show up in some
form of a 1099 so this is an example of
a 1099 for miscellaneous information
misc Miss 1099 Miss right over here but
there are 1099s for say interest you get
on your bank account there are 10.99s
for dividends a 1099 can be useful let's
say if you're an independent contractor
so you're getting income it's not coming
from an employer it's coming from some
type of a company that hired you to do
something but they're not giving you
benefits Etc so a lot of folks might
have a 1099 of some form for that other
income that income that you're not
getting for your employer and you'll get
one 1099 let's say you have two bank
accounts they're each giving you
interest you'll get 129 10.99 from each
of those once again very useful when
you're filling out your taxes
now the last form I'm going to show you
is most relevant well especially this
version right over here the 1090 a 1098
is actually to document interest that
you have paid to other parties or other
types of money outflows I should say
that might be tax deductible so this one
right over here this 1098 is a mortgage
interest statement in many cases the
interest that you pay on the mortgage on
your actual house so not a rental
property not a second house but on your
actual house that is oftentimes interest
deductible and another case there might
be even cases where some of those other
examples where the mortgage interest is
actually deductible as well but this one
if you when you get this statement from
whoever you're paying your your mortgage
payments to whoever you're borrowing
from this will also be useful when you
are filling out your taxes if you to
even see if you qualify for the that
mortgage interest deduction
so I'll stop there there's many other
tax forms but these are the ones that
most people are going to encounter